[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it's great to be here at CES again
next month PlayStation VR2 launches a
new generation of virtual reality
experiences
that enable players to feel a greater
sense of presence and Escape into Worlds
like never before
the launch lineup for psvr2 will take VR
Gaming to new heights
more than 30 games are currently on
track for the launch window including
much-loved franchises with Horizon call
of the mountain
no man's sky and Resident Evil Village
these games showcase psvr2's ability to
immerse players and to Captivate their
senses in new ways
leveraging the Hardware's next 10
next-gen sensory features and the power
of PlayStation 5.
today I'm excited to announce that one
of our most storied franchises will be
coming to psvr2 at launch
Gran Turismo a game which has sold more
copies across the series than any other
title developed by PlayStation Studios
gt7 launched last year to critical
acclaim
and through a free upgrade
psvr2 players will be able to experience
the game like never before
psvr2 launches globally on February 22nd
and you can pre-order now on
playstation.com
and that's just the beginning I'm happy
to announce that one of the VR games
that defines the medium is in
development for psvr 2. beat saver
the award-winning and best-selling VR
rhythm game is coming to Playstation VR2
and we'll have more information to share
in the near future
psvr2 is just the latest example of
innovation from PlayStation
we're always challenging ourselves to
create new player experiences for our
community of Gamers around the world
as that Community continues to grow with
new players it's our mission to make
those experiences accessible to all
Gamers regardless of their physical
abilities
today I'm thrilled to announce our next
step in the journey to make gaming more
accessible project Leonardo
our code name for a new PS5
accessibility controller kit that will
allow players with disabilities to play
more easily
more comfortably and for longer periods
project Leonardo is highly customizable
thank you and works out of the box
providing a robust kit of swappable
components and a suite of software
options on PS5
it's a true canvas that enables many
gamers with disabilities to craft their
own play experience
it can be used as a standalone
controller
or paired with a second project Leonardo
controller or a dual sense wireless
controller
we'd like to thank wonderful
organizations like ablegamers
special effect
Stack Up and several other accessibility
experts who are supporting us on this
journey and we can't wait to share more
details soon
sitting at the heart of all this
Innovation is PS5
we truly appreciate the support and
patience of the PlayStation Community as
we managed unprecedented demand amid
Global challenges over the past two
years
PS5 Supply improved towards the end of
last year
and I'm happy to share that December was
the biggest month ever for PS5 console
sales and that we've now sold more than
30 million units through to Consumers
worldwide
everyone who wants a PS5 should have a
much easier time finding one at
retailers globally starting from this
point forward
with psvr 2's launch around the corner
and Blockbuster games like Final Fantasy
16. Hogwarts Legacy and Marvel
Spider-Man 2 coming to PS5 later this
year it's never been a more exciting
time to be part of the PlayStation
Community thank you
foreign